premier élément le protocole sanitaire
ce protocole sanitaire vous l'avez dit
il sera diffusé vendredi
on est dans la dernière ligne droite
avec consultation des associations
d'élus des organisations syndicales mais
entendu il est surtout basé sur le
travail du conseil scientifique et des
autorités sanitaires
il est indépassable autrement dit si on
ne le respecte pas on n'ouvre pas une
école ou un ou un établissement
ce protocole gelé là il a été travaillé
avec le bureau veritas pour avoir des
fiches très clair sur chacun des sujets
et sur les sujets que vous évoquez comme
la cantine l'internât toute la
désinfection des locaux
tous ces points sont traités et donc on
doit les respecter c'est le sujet le
plus national en réalité le plus cadran
des trois sujets deuxième sujet c'est la
doctrine d'accueil c'est à dire quels
sont les enfants qui viennent quand
comment et ceci suppose vous l'avez dit
une communication avec les familles ce
que je demandais aux recteurs et aux
dizaines et avec eux à l'ensemble des
acteurs de l'éducation nationale c'est
de faire ce que nous avons réussi à
faire pendant le confinement c'est à
dire communiquer avec les familles très
en amont du 11
dès que l'on commence à avoir une
organisation locale défini et on a vu
dans les propos du premier ministre que
c'était une organisation spécifique à
chaque fois et bien l'école et la
famille comme unique notamment pour
savoir si la famille souhaite envoyer
les que l'enfant à l'école
si ça n'est pas le cas c'est un
enseignement à distance qui se réalise
car l'instruction est obligatoire même à
distance soit tout simplement pour voir
quel est l'emploi du temps de l'enfant
et comment les choses s'organisent
cette communication entre les acteurs
est fondamentale et notamment entre
l'école et la famille et puis en
troisième lieu une doctrine et
pédagogiques et éducatives sur plan
pédagogique on est au coeur de la
compétence de l'éducation nationale son
plan éducatif c'est aussi avec les
communes et sur l'ensemble de ces sujets
le dialogue comme une école et est
fondamental vous l'avez dit et là bien
entendu c'est de la co construction avec
les maires qui se réalise sur tous les
aspects pratiques comme ceux que vous
avez mentionné c'est à dire par exemple
nombre de salles disponibles mais aussi
pour évaluer ensemble le nombre
d'enfants qui viennent l'organisation
générale la coopération complète qui
doit exister entre l'éducation nationale
et les communes je dois dire qu'avec les
associations d'élus avec qui nous avons
encore parlé ce matin avec le premier
ministre
le climat est à la confiance et le
climat est à la construction